on retrouve ce soir Clément Gignac
économiste sénateur indépendant du
Québec il est à Ottawa bonsoir Clément
Gignac bonsoir est-ce que le rachat de
crédit Suisse par UBS était la meilleure
chose à faire et est-ce que ça reçoit
tout le monde selon vous mais je pense
que pour les clients puis les déposer un
oui c'était la même chose à faire la
meilleure chose à faire je suis pas sûr
pour les actionnaires toutefois on
pourra en reparler mais je pense que le
gouvernement suisse avait décidé que
assez cétacé on avait avancé la Banque
Nationale ça va avancer 50 milliards la
semaine passée et on voyait que c'était
pas suffisant donc on a choisi
l'acheteur donc un concurrent yubs comme
vous savez pour être sûr que ça reste
très comme propriété un peu plus au
niveau de la Suisse au lieu de ça soit
une banque étrangère qui fasse
acquisition des actifs mais à 3
milliards 200 millions de dollars
américains c'est un prix dérisoire
l'action de créditif a chuté aujourd'hui
c'est quoi le message que cette
transaction envoie sur l'incertitude
bancaire en ce moment mais pour dire
c'est un prix dérisoire oui c'était
beaucoup moins élevé que la valeur
boursière du vendredi précédent qui
avait déjà baissé 90% mais en fait
c'était à 10% de la valeur au livre
Géral donc un peu une aubaine j'irai
pour UBS d'acheter un concurrent le
message est celui-ci c'est que pour les
actionnaires les clients les déposants
sont rassurés on sait que il y a
quelqu'un qui veille au grain mais pour
les actionnaires ben les banques ça peut
comporter aussi un risque surtout si une
banque qui était plus ou moins bien
gérée que des problèmes ben si vous êtes
un actionnaire de banque vous n'êtes pas
aussi bien protégé qu'un déposant ou un
client d'une banque est-ce qu'il est
préférable qu'une banque achète une
autre banque comme c'est le cas ou que
le gouvernement rend flou la banque pour
la sauver mais rendu un certain je pense
qu'on vient de tirer de leçon de 2008 en
2008 c'était les gouvernements qui
venaient à l'intervention on devenait
actionnaire des banques on laissait le
management en place on a tiré le son
2008 puis les politiciens veulent plus
vivre la chaleur qui ont vécu les
critiques qui ont subi en 2002 à
l'époque j'étais
spécial vous savez Ottawa et clairement
les politiciens par la suite c'est pas
des choses qui veulent vraiment avoir
quand il voit différemment cette fois-ci
d'ailleurs j'avais pas conseillé
sincèrement de d'être actionnaire puis
au Canada on le gouvernement je m'étais
actionnaire des banques canadiennes
évidemment je parlais du tout donc
clairement je pense c'est de la bonne
chose à faire c'est que maintenant on
donne plus autant la chance au
management on dit ok il y a un problème
on va le régler et selon moi c'est la
bonne chose à faire il y a-t-il des
risques de contagion quand même des
faillites bancaires américaines des
troupes de crédit Suisse selon vous mais
ces deux dossiers différents Crédit
Suisse une mauvaise gestion des actifs
les actifs avaient diminué 30% l'année
passée donc clairement le marché est un
mal à l'aise avec ce qui se passait
mauvaise réputation on aurait de les
problèmes aux États-Unis c'est un autre
sujet oui on voit les titres en bourse
qui baisent beaucoup mais c'est que dans
le cas silicone valise c'était une
petite c'est une banque quand même assez
grosse on parle de la 16e bande mais qui
est concentré à Silicon Valley très peu
financiers contrairement à des grosses
banques comme JP Morgan ou nos banques
canadiennes et là clairement c'est une
gestion de leur dépôts ils ont investi
dans des titres à long terme des titres
sécures gouvernement américain des des
hypothèques là-bas mais investi à long
terme alors que les dépôts sont à court
terme donc clairement quand les pertes
ont dû se matérialiser il y a une crise
de confiance et les gens ont pris
panique et on a vu ce que ça donne mais
qu'est-ce qui doit se passer par exemple
avec la first-fer publique Bang qui est
en difficulté qui est la troisième
banque en importance aux États-Unis
après premièrement je pense pas qu'on
voit de faillite additionnelle dans les
deux trois prochaines semaines deux
trois prochains mois à Z à Washington on
va trouver des solutions pour pas qu'on
voit d'autres fêtes de banque parce que
ça amène l'inquiétude chez des déposants
des clients par contre les actionnaires
se c'est une autre affaire donc je serai
pas surpris qu'on fasse faire République
Bank à émettre d'autres capitales ou
sinon accepter une acquisition d'une
autre banque parce qu'il y a pas
question à Washington qu'on contélèrent
d'autres
faillites mais ça sera beaucoup plus de
réglementation au niveau des banques
régionales et ça c'est pour dire
dilution du côté des actionnaires quand
les banques centrales se mettent à
parler tout ensemble puis intervenir la
fin de semaine entre deux séances de
marché
il y a des doutes qui soulèvent quand
même là on a vu une intervention des
banques centrales 6 banques dont la
Banque du Canada pour assurer la
liquidité l'accès au dollar américain
est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce que ça nous
dit ça cette intervention là ben c'est
moins d'un resserrement des conditions
financières et ça ça pourrait influencer
également la Réserve fédérale de ne pas
augmenter taux d'intérêt parce que oui
on a demandé qu'on veut ramener
l'inflation en 2% mais on veut pas
amener une dépression économique on veut
pas avoir de l'Apocalypse là on veut un
ralentissement de l'économie et là s'il
y a un désordre au niveau des marchés
financiers une restriction de liquidité
bien à ce moment-là on va intervenir de
façon chirurgicale et je serai pas
surpris peut-être qu'ils vont monter
taux d'intérêt cette semaine parait de
25 points de base mais on va signaler
que là on s'envoie ces lignes de côté et
c'est vraiment la fin des hausses de
taux aux États-Unis décision mercredi un
dernier mot sur la ministrehaeline la
ministre des Finances qui dit que le
Canada était essentiellement finalement
à l'abri des problèmes bancaires ce que
vous êtes d'accord je serai d'accord
l'idée c'est que je pense qu'on est à
l'abri mais on sait jamais qu'est-ce qui
peut arriver dans 5 ou 10 ans mais les
banques canadiennes sont très bien
diversifiées à travers les régions à
travers les secteurs sont très bien
capitalisés alors qu'aux États-Unis on
est au-delà de 5000 au-delà de 4000
institutions de dépôts et là à ce
moment-là c'est une situation
complètement différente donc moi rassuré
ou comme client déposant au Canada qu'on
verrait pas ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis quant à la barre leur
boursière des titres on le voit que les
titres bancaires Canadiens se comportent
beaucoup mieux que l'étude bancaires
américains européens ils ont baissé
beaucoup moins merci Clément Gignac
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir au plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI